ISIS just claimed a major new terror attack in the Belgian capital of Brussels
to understand why they would do this, you have to look at something that changed for ISIS about a year ago
and pretty far away in the middle east
So ISIS in the summer of 2014
had had a huge sweep across the region, seizing lots of cities
Starting in early 2015, the group began to suffer some real defeats in Syria and Iraq
lost some major cities and started to come under attack from American airstrikes
and in just a few months it lost a quarter of its territory
but this posed more than just a military threat to ISIS
It had always operated on a narrative of victory and invinsibility
and it used that to recruit and motivate fighters of other Jihadist groups
and it needs those fighters to survive
the was caliphate was losing ground so it was losing that narrative
and it needed something new to keep that going so
first they tried to expand abroad, Libya, Afghanistan, Yemen
but those efforts all fizzled, in the summer and fall of 2015
ISIS found its solution, by launching mass terror attacks against civilians abroad
and this helped the group portray itself once again as on the march
but then Europe faced a big problem in how to deal with these attacks
because the hard truth is that most of these attackers aren't foreigners. They aren't refugees or migrants
they're actually European nationals
and you can't just close the border to keep them out if they're actually from Europe
and a lot of them are people who went and joined ISIS or other terrorist groups, so-called foreign fighters
and now that ISIS is losing territory, those fighters are coming home, and they're bringing
their battled hardened experience and skills with them
and these are really hard problems to solve, rooted in socio-economic problems
grievances that go pretty deep in European society
you can't solve this with bombs or with border closings
So what now?
It seems likely that as ISIS keeps losing its territory
its going to become something like what it was before, when America was fighting the Iraq war in the mid 2000's
Not a state, but still an insurgency and a terrorist group
capable of doing terrible damage abroad.